luego de ejecutoria la sentencia a 8
años de prisión el tribunal de la corte
nacional de justicia ha emitido la orden
de captura en contra de 19 procesados
del caso sobornos lo cual incluye
también a rafael correa luego de que dos
jueces de la corte nacional de justicia
emitiera en la orden a la policía
nacional debe solicitarse la captura en
contra de rafael correa- recordemos que
esto se debe por el caso en sobornos por
el cual es rafael correa deberá ser en
todo caso se abre la solicitud para su
captura luego de esto debe cumplirse
también el procedimiento por parte de la
interpol que compete en la solicitud la
revisión y la respuesta por parte de la
interpol recordemos que en todo caso
esta sería la tercera solicitud de
captura en contra de rafael correa- las
dos primeras habrían sido realizadas por
el caso del secuestro de la activista
fernando val da igual forma ahora por el
caso de sobornos pero esto tenía
generado algunas reacciones
internacionales por parte
representantes ex presidentes
cancilleres que paralelamente también
piden a través de una carta al ejecutivo
nacional es revisar cuál es el estatus
de la democracia en el país andino de
igual forma también se exhorta al
ministerio de finanzas se ordena
suspender la pensión vitalicia que
recibía el ex mandatario de ecuador
rafael correa y su ex vicepresidente
jorge glass y también la sentencia
contempla algunas reparaciones
simbólicas por parte de los 19
procesados a favor del estado